[Applause]
chair of the executive committee of
nickel Awards fellows Eric
welcome everyone to the 2022 Nickel
fellowships in screenwriting Awards and
live read
my name is Eric heiserer I'm a member of
the writers branch of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences and
chair of the nickel committee
Tonight We Gather for an incredible
story told on Hallowed Ground the land
of the tongfa people its original
caretakers
we honor tongfa ancestors and the Tango
Community today which continues to
nurture this land and water through
traditional practices activism art and
education
we also honor indigenous communities
around the world the early storytellers
which brings me to our purpose tonight
to nurture Empower and celebrate an
inclusive community of storytellers of
writers this is the nickel fellowship's
Mission first launched in 1986 by an
amazing woman Gladys G Nichol a mission
informed by G's career as an actor and
writer and inspired by the life of her
beloved writer producer husband Don
nickel
cut to 2022 and G's Vision has become
kind of a success
since its Inception 37 years ago the
nickel competition has received over 188
000 entries
and only 176 fellowships have been
awarded
as such being named Nico fellow is a big
deal
here's some more numbers this year alone
the competition received
5526 scripts from an astounding 84
different countries
these stories and all their stages of
development and success were judged by
83 professional readers including
graduates of the Academy's diverse
reader training Workshop then 178
Academy members winnowed down those
scripts through more rounds of judging
in the end my incomparable Fellowship
committee colleagues and I chose the
Nichols newest fellows six in all
authors of five exemplary screenplays
tonight we'll meet these new fellows
we'll witness their winning screenplays
brought to life
but for me beyond the competition
process it's Global reach it's 35 000
prize it's mentorship opportunities the
evolution of Gene Nichols vision is
about the Deep connections made between
the tinkle fellows
I'm a writer first and foremost so the
power of the nickel story is about
advocating for this special community of
writers not only across the year-long
fellowship but in the years that come
after
now due to the pandemic we were unable
to celebrate the 2021 fellows in person
last year please join me in welcoming to
the stage our 2021 nickel fellows Haley
hope artels
Karen delapena Collison
Byron Hamel
RJ Daniel Hannah
and Laura Kosen
I know there's a lot of hard work that
led to winning the fellowship
maybe you still remember getting that
call from the nickel committee
together with a 21-2021 fellows we are
very excited to share the story of six
extraordinary screenwriters tonight and
here's the moment they became the newest
members of our nickel family
[Music]